Marshall how are you this morning I'm
glad I'm great everyone they're great we
were just talking TV shows impactful TV
shows favorite TV show of all time is
what oh man probably one that I learned
the most from by the kid good times
really what'd you learn oh man just just
family how to stick together when James
was a part of the show today I when
James wasn't a part of the show they
really taught as a as a african-american
kid growing up you got to see what it
was like to have a father you got to see
what it was like to not have a father
and have a strong mother the
interactions between two brothers
between brothers and sisters when they
get along and when they don't get along
um yet the artistic guy in JJ the
talented guy and Michael you know we
really couldn't figure out Michael like
where he was at that point in time in
his life but you gave us all right you
gave it time and that was early it's not
for real that was early with sexuality
you know and in the show in that point
in time it was you know they were they
were kind of flirting with something not
saying it but saying it hmm at a real
early time and it just it was like wow
but everything's normal and obviously
janet was on there gaining its neighbor
and it was it was it was it was a really
funny show to show that it was it was
light-hearted there was a lot of jokes
but a lot of a lot of family values came
out of good times but you're saying that
you watch differently than most would
that you're watching to understand
having a father figure and what he meant
on the family dynamic oh just everything
I mean that was not just a father figure
but a strong mother who worked a family
I was struggling but they were a family
I mean I don't know if you understood
but I always only counted two bedrooms
you gave us a lot of thought Marshall it
was three kids two boys JJ slept on the
couch in the living room we never really
knew where Michael slept it's good
that's good did you ever meet Jimmy
Walker no no I never did never did I saw
where you did something with Arnold
Palmer I did I did now how did that
happen so II a sport they're all about
cross branding athletes in two different
integrating athletes in two different
games and I had a character in a tiger
woods game now Rory game that you could
unlock and I shot some stuff with Arnold
Palmer I was it was like a commercial
that they ran uh it was more like a leva
so that they ran where are the watch me
hit some shots and was giving me tips
and kind of telling me you know maybe
you have a future I'll no stick to
football and just just giving me a hard
time about about how much easier golf
may appear then football from the
physical aspect but uh kind of teasing
me about not being able to maybe get the
ball out of a bunker just stuff like
that so it was uh we've got some time
together and it was it was fun it was
fine he's marshal funk the hall of famer
from the NFL Network joining a Stan
Patrick show poll question today is
who's in more trouble Carolina or
Arizona oh man um i'ma go Arizona mine I
go Arizona I think that I think the NFC
West is it's a harder fight to fall to a
1 and 3 hold and try to dig yourself out
of the Rams get a facial making win
football game they can dominate the
liners from
Jim football games and we know what
Seattle is going to bring to the table
san Francisco's not an easy win even for
the Cowboys is just not an easy win and
when I look at Carolina some of the
things it appears that they can fix like
they're back in their secondary old guys
but they're eventually going to learn
how to how to play together and and then
and then when you look at the day NFC
South you know you you feel like okay
Tampa New Orleans Carolina they should
get some wins against those those teams
I don't think the division is that
strong yeah I'm just trying to figure
out what's going on with Carol explain
to me what happened with that secondary
with Julio Jones yesterday dan there's
no explanation for what happened i mean
ii they I torch death but that is just
you know we run up against a freak of
nature like Leo Jones and then you just
allow him to run free in your secondary
um that's a doctor that's a nightmare
that is a nightmare at that on any given
Sunday you he commands attention and he
deserves respect that you make sure that
other guys have to beat you and and
Carolina was they were just out there
playing like Julio Jones was just wanted
to die but I don't understand that
though at what point do you say I think
Julio is good and we might have to put
two guys or we have to sort of shade
somebody to that side with him how about
this and I'm and I think this is what
happened I was at the game in New
Orleans on Monday night and the Saints
they dedicated rolled coverage and
compromise some coverages paying
attention to Julio and some other guys
and running backs were running free and
I think Carolina said okay we can't just
allow that to happen so a superstar drew
some attention in the game and the next
week
teen said okay left my give him as much
attention and he did what he was
supposed to do this now now you look at
who's next for Atlanta they have to
decide okay how do we play julio jones
because if you watch the gaming as New
Orleans the two running backs oh my god
Demonte Freeman Tevin Coleman had a
field day with catching balls out of the
backfield because they were spinning so
they were rolling coverages to Julio
Jones and they were run Julio on
crossing route and put the back in and
in the flat or catch the bag back in the
void he make a linebacker miss and it
would be nobody else for 20 yards crazy
so I mean it's just a Kyle Shanahan do a
great job at I coming up with some being
to help and it calls from issues for
Carolina now you know obviously kill
honor did you have to say that they're
missing Josh Norman more than more than
Josh Norman missing Carolina right now
do you think that there's part of Bella
check that he's okay with that loss he's
not going to say it but they lost
there's no talk of going undefeated now
Brady is back almost you now we're
hitting the reset button and you know
worth worth three and one how do you
think public feels that way I think
Belichick is is is there they are losses
that he's okay with let's say last year
AFC Championship Denver Broncos what
denver did how they won 15 play really
good night game something happen fine
they didn't play the kind of the brand
of football that he likes to play if you
beat him at his game which is you come
up with one or two things that he hadn't
seen one or two wrinkles you sprinkle in
he's fine with that but they did not
play found solid football so he was
pissed by me you saw him on a fine line
throws you rarely get at much emotion
you rarely get that much emotion out of
auto bill you know but that game was
still there
for them to take it and they just they
couldn't make enough plays and and and I
go back I don't know if you caught our
show you know I just I said the Houston
Texans showed up and they were not ready
for what happened to them to happen to
them with the rookie quarterback either
you need that please I mean it should
have been a defensive battle at best let
alone you guys just get shut out that it
said that they were they were so
ill-prepared that uh it I actually was
upset I'm not gonna lie I was upset that
that was our gate I have fun on Thursday
night you're looking good man how many
pounds all I dropped I like like 40 know
you dropped more than that you jus
dropped about 15 right around there yeah
you look good yeah yeah you gotta sing
it back for it I got to 2pac 2pac shakur
I love it ilona two more than I had
Thank You Marshall good to talk to you
all right that's a martial funk NFL
network the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience